é muito voltada a todas e todos um
momento nenhuma casa sob o nariz
internacional portugal
sou do bem sou feminista mas não
necessariamente por esta ordem
eu queria crescer a jogada porque queria
ajudar a combater as injustiças no mundo
depois entrei pra área de direitos
humanos e em seguida parte 4 é igualdade
entre homens e mulheres e acaba por
tornar uma feminista mas ainda não
tivesse um pessoal sobre ter mais
influência sobre estes pequenos passos
que eu estou a tentar fazer pra mudar o
mundo foi meu pai desde muito nova
meu pai dizia que eu eu sei que eu
tomava em relação ao meu corpo para
espanha também decisões em relação à
minha vida é só no trabalho
em relação às minhas mãos
relacionamentos e também pessoal as
grades que eu era muito mais do que
minha biologia e que é porque somos
todos mais do que a nossa biologia que
estou aqui hoje porque todos podemos
tomar as mesmas decisões que meu pai lhe
disse que eu podia tomar
fala se muito em povoamento mulheres
hoje em dia como uma nova concessão
decorrer do desafio ao poder dominante
dos homens sobre as mulheres dos
privilégios de gênero
é como se uma mudança não é para
garantir a autonomia sobre o corpo e
sobre a sexualidade nem poderia ter
muito mais do que isso internamente
todos nós todos nós temos o direito de
max e em relação à nossa menina
temos o direito a ser pessoas ea seguir
o nosso tempo e isso é o empoderamento
para todos e para todas e agora para
quebrar o gelo criado já tem todos os
olhos durante o chute eo e treinando com
o público fazer a mesma coisa
vamos todos pensar numa experiência
sexual agradável durante 58
agora podem abrir os olhos e olhem pro
lado e compensou avançada que pensava
agora quebrado jean agora entrada do
dinheiro eles que eu quero falar hoje
quero falar sobre os vossos direitos
sexuais e proteger os direitos sexuais e
reprodutivos são essenciais para nós
usuários de todos os nossos direitos
humanos em particular e por exemplo o
nosso direito à vida nas directas o
nosso está inclinado física e
psicológica
o nosso direito à liberdade de expressão
a liberdade de consciência a nossa vida
privada nossa vida se molhar mas os
direitos sexuais e reprodutivos não só
das guerras nem podemos pensar que as
mesmas são as primeiras vítimas
vulneráveis de violência ou só no papel
mas que também não podemos pensar nos
homens como as únicas pessoas
responsáveis por essa influência dos
direitos sexuais e reprodutivos são
todos nós e tem 120 por todos nós
entender o alan
quando faltam mais direitos sexuais e
reprodutivos que também pensa nos outros
dois com sites a lançar que é o
empoderamento e autonomia e quando a
autonomia é o direito à autonomia e
todas as pessoas de verem as suas
relações pessoais e sociais e não só o
mero ato fisiológico da produção da
nossa vida sexual e reprodutiva italiana
é todos os aspectos das nossas vidas
trazer os dois casos o internacional
entrou na final
mal se está em crianças na nossa família
e filhas sobrinhas sobrinhos primos
primos netos e netas
à menos de um mês eu fui a vítima que
possui enorme e fique eo meu irmão eu
sou bonita mas não tanto de repente
senti uma força militar em nota ter uma
sobrinha chamada maria e foi uma
sensação maravilhosa uma sensação mágica
realmente as crianças são uma presença
maravilhosa nas nossas vidas e há poucas
semanas atrás o grupo islâmico armado
chamado vou colar a raptou mais duas
centenas de raparigas na nigéria
entraram na escola e uvaranas em
caminhões
organizados segundo os quatis e foram
embora eles apareceram sem qualquer
empreendimento total a esquecer as
brigas são a ser vendidas para serem
escravas sexuais e para casarem à força
agora imaginem as nossas filhas e as
nossas metas e as vossas primas e as
vossas sobrinhas
eram estas raparigas imagina o desespero
dessas famílias em dois trechos
isso aconteceu na nigéria há muito muito
pouco tempo que eles têm direito à
educação não sei se não só tem o direito
universal como ter direito de ver livre
de violência o governo e tem que
garantir que as suas preferidas oferecem
segurança de suas casas e todos temos
que agir agora todos e todas e podemos
fazer vários maridos diferentes por
exemplo assinado uma petição
nós temos que encontrar alguma forma a
garantir os direitos da autonomia das
mulheres e o controle sobre os seus
corpos e sobre sua sexualidade não é só
das mulheres de todas as pessoas porque
todos nós somos pessoas não somos
objetos dos quais quatro por que te por
governos devem garantir às pessoas o
direito de usufruir sem medo e sem
coação e sem discriminação dos seus
direitos sexuais e reprodutivos e queria
avançar com três exemplos os
compromissos e os progressos que que o
estado tem feito esse progresso somente
são desiguais
só em 2012 por exemplo 43% da população
do mundo tenha entre 16 e 24 anos e
nessa população 90 por cento vivem em
países em desenvolvimento onde o acesso
só girar e na educação sexual e
reprodutiva é muito muito limitado a
grande maioria das pessoas não conhece
essa educação é essencial às vexes em 41
por cento dos novos casos de hiv são
pessoas entre 15 e 24 anos e queria um
terceiro exemplo mas para isso preciso
vontade do público mas pode chegar aqui
só chegou aqui deixar tretas
inflacionária
como é que chama de olávio antônia tudo
bem
olha eu sei que acabamos nos conhecermos
muito ter um favor muito especial
é preciso dar um beijo na boca não te
importar z tem mesmo que ser fácil para
a apresentação mesmo mesmo obrigada
foi muito simpático e os voluntários
hotel é muito simpático foi implantado
somente simpático beijar alguém em
público em marrocos
se nós fôssemos os dois ambos gente
pegar pena de prisão por conduta
indecorosa está despontando em um livro
que todas as pessoas fazem sem pensar
hoje em dia às vezes com conhecidos e às
vezes contra os princípios neste caso
poderia em hawks dar pena de prisão se
caso fosse usado um chat e na mínima pra
casar e marrocos são 18 anos mas em 2010
contabilizados mais de 44 mil raparigas
que casaram entre os 15 e os 18 anos e
apesar do item natural pra casar cedo os
18 anos 92 por cento das posições dos
juízes para as pessoas poderem casar com
menos do que com menos de 18 anos são a
site
o segundo caso que o estrago e nível
nacional em que uma mulher que foi alvo
do mel violência lixo no jornal há pouco
mais de uma semana e fica aí
extremamente para nós vermos que os
problemas dos direitos das mulheres não
só em países longínquos e em
desenvolvimento que são mesmo aqui ao
lado é um prato uma reunião no seu
escritório a procon uma cliente e com o
marido foi assassinada pelo marido da
senhora que estava a defender o que pra
ter motivado o neste artigo do jornal
explicou a situação esta pessoa fazer
isso senti isso o trajeto para o
primeiro ministro sobre a sua mulher
sentiu que estava a perder o privilégio
estar casado como vem o espaço são
precisos lá e é preciso dar a primeira
transmissão do domínio dos homens sobre
as mulheres não só nos outros países
também são em portugal
deixo aqui meu voto de pesar ana paula
de souza é que no exercício da profissão
que abraçou teve a coragem de defender
uma mulher que estava a ser vítima de
violência doméstica e ela própria se
tornou alvo de violência e acho que tem
que fazer
porque todos os dias vemos este passo
atrás na busca da justiça né na procura
do flamengo né na igualdade entre homens
e mulheres na igualdade entre todos nós
e temos todos que fazer alguma coisa em
relação a este temos todos que nos
indignar
em relação a estas situações e agora
imaginem os passos que são precisos para
conter estes números 150 milhões de
raparigas com menos de 18 anos só de
minas sem fome hoje 2000 e 2011 2020 142
milhões de raparigas vão casar enquanto
ainda são crianças 14 milhões de
raparigas vão dar à luz todos os anos
por resultado de uma maioria não é só em
sexuais forçadas e gravidezes
indesejadas e 215 milhões de mulheres
não têm acesso a contraceptivos mas
afinal o que são os nossos direitos
sexuais e reprodutivos de todos nós na
nigéria em portugal em qualquer preço
eu irei tomar decisões em relação à
nossa saúde
a nossa sexualidade sem temos medo dos
30 criminalização dos nossos lados e
temos direito à informação sou contra
acessar o planeamento familiar saúde
materna o direito de decidir se queremos
ter filhos quando queremos ter filhos e
quantos filhos queremos ter e o direito
de escolher o nosso companheiro ou a
nossa companheira se queremos casar ou
não queremos casar e quando queremos
casado
acima de tudo viver livres de qualquer
discriminação e violência ou coação e os
estados os estados o que podem fazer
podem deixar de usar mais ações penais
que criminalizam a nossa sexualidade ea
nossa produção podem proteger a
autonomia das pessoas na tomada de
decisões sobre a sua sexualidade e podem
evitar que o controle o uso por
terceiros também podem encontrar as
pessoas poderem exercer os seus direitos
e imprimir a discriminação por todo o
mundo as pessoas sofrem quando continuam
a ser impedidos de fazer essas escolhas
e por último queria só duas chaves com
duas meias finais o que todos
fazer para gerar esta mudança deve
começar por tentar convencer os estados
a respeitar os direitos sexuais e
reprodutivos parece uma ideia bastante
simples
depois também podemos mobilizar os como
ativistas como simpatizante ou
simplesmente como opinião pública para
que jovens e jovens conheçam os seus
direitos sexuais e reprodutivos e não
esqueçam uma coisa que estes direitos
são universais são de todos nós não só
dos homens ou duas mulheres ou das
crianças são todos e todas e vamos todos
pensar em conjunto nos passos que temos
e que vivemos bar para avançar lançámos
de proteção desses direitos e para
combatermos esses números
eu quero deixar aqui como o ema que eu
gostei muito e que usa pra mim que é o
seguinte
amar é sentir lutado passear houve
explorar a abraçar é periciado e eu é
preciso como tive o meu corpo
muito obrigada